Prince Harry is back at work and
launching his first project since his
royal exit on Monday the 35 year old
mental health advocate launched head fit
a new website with tools and resources
to help military personnel take a more
proactive approach to their mental
health and mental fitness today when we
talk about Fitness we don't just mean
how fast you can run or how much weight
you can carry this is about mental
fitness strength and resilience not just
while wearing a uniform but for the rest
of your life
Harry opens up about the new platform in
a video posted to the website if you
want to be truly fit strong and healthy
you need to train your mind and body as
one head fit is a resource for everyone
whatever your job whatever your rank
whatever you've got going on at home
head fit has been in the works for three
years with the Ministry of Defense and
the Royal foundations heads together
campaign which Harry launched in 2016
along with big brother Prince William
and sister-in-law Kate Middleton's first
pin assess in the military with yourself
an addiction with me and bereavement as
I said underlying threat wasn't that
meant enough and this idea that fizzles
us coming together to find the colour
theme in a statement Harry explains his
motivation for creating this new
platform quote I've long believed the
military community should lead the way
for the rest of society for too long we
have been waiting for problems to arise
and then reacting to them all service
personnel of vital role models in
society and we need you to be able to
access that extra 10 maybe 15% something
that can only be attained when you adopt
a regular routine for training the mind
and the body as one single unit
I know this to be true it works for me
head fit marks Harry's first major
project since he and wife Megan Markel
stepped down from royal duties on March
31st
the couple is currently living in LA
with their almost one-year-old son
Archie we're like the rest of the world
they have been practicing social
distancing amid the corona virus
pandemic but they've still managed to
find ways to give back I think Megan and
Harry had clearly had a few weeks of
just they're not a couple they'd like to
sit still and they didn't waste much
time getting to work delivering food
parcels to vulnerable people in the city
who can't get to shop royal expert Katie
Nichol tells ET that Megan and Harry
really want to be hands-on with their
work you may not have the use of his
title that he will always be Prince
Harry I think this is bigger than
celebrity I think this is about them
wanting to use you know they're very
unique platforms to to do some good to
go and do their their charity work and
to really make a difference unlocking
your potential and strive to be Hedford
[Music]